Some of them are vegetarians so they won't eat you.
Children know dinosaurs.
Even though they've never actually seen one.
T-Rex and stegosaurus, triceratops, and... ankylosaurus.
How old are they? I don't even know.
Kinda like your parents?
Yeah, kind of.
But dinosaurs are extinct, right?
They don't really live, right?
They do! The real ones are in there!
He's right.
Inside, it's a travel back in time,...
...more than a hundred million years ago, when dinosaurs ruled.
This is a baby brachiosaurus and its mother.
She towers above the arena at 11 meters tall and 17 meters long.
The bracs are part of the traveling show, "Walking with Dinosaurs".
It's a 20-million-dollar production, where animatronics add to the realism.
Here's how it works in rehearsals.
Stegosaurus lumbers in at 5 and 1/2 meters tall and 11 meters high.
Next to him stands the armored ankylosaurus.
The 17 dinosaurs in the show are covered with elasticized mesh filled with polystyrene balls.
The fabric skin contracts and stretches across muscles and bones, just like on real creatures.
Three people activate each dinosaur by remote control.
Two of them stand among the audience and work at what's called a voodoo rig.
The voodoo rig is actually a mechanical miniaturized version of a dinosaur.
This is the body.
This is the area of the spine and the neck.
And, this is the head.
So, when the puppeteer moves the apparatus,...
...it remotely sends a signal to the floor and, in turn, the dinosaur moves.